you mentioned uh being a songwriter
first
how often do you lent your pen to other
artists
recently not that much you know what i'm
saying because to the point where
i was just having this conversation the
other day um i had wrote a verse for
beyonce it's savage remix you know what
i'm saying but uh my verse didn't get
used and just off that simple fact of me
taking my time on my day to write some
[ __ ] and it don't get you i ain't got
time to be
you know what i'm saying just
pausing my day to get a placement so
i don't know it's it's if i get if i get
a call i'm you know saying say beyonce
around to call me right now and say come
to the studio
and write this
and pull up but i'm not about to do the
middle man send it to somebody
yeah no that's a the hustle and bustle
of the game it's like the producer game
i'd be feeling bad because producers be
really just chomping at the bit just to
get that placement to get that placement
you know what i'm saying and i ain't got
time for that if it's direct i'm with it
but as far as like
i ain't doing that run around so with
the beyonce situation someone had
reached out to a middle person that
reached out to you he really wasn't the
middle man he was he was the man right
but you know what i'm saying like before
that before i wrote that i ain't really
wrote nobody's [ __ ] in a minute i don't
even i always turn so you would just
submitted a verse i was just doing he
said beyonce i was like [ __ ] all right
right right but you know saying when it
didn't land i'm like come on man you
should just kept whoever you called
first they got diversity you know i said
just let him just do it you feel me but
ain't no ain't no bad feelings bad blood
that's the game that's did she do you
know if she cut the verse or no you
don't know i don't know i never met
beyonce that'd be yeah i mean that'd be
crazy that'd be crazy though i'mma get
one though